Europe hebdo - 24 mai 2013
bonjour et bienvenue à strasbourg au
parlement européen pour cette nouvelle
édition d'ailleurs à peine deux ans
le reportage de la semaine à 5 face aux
catalans qui veulent s'affranchir de
madrid
pour former un nouvel état pourquoi ce
désir d'autonomie pour le savoir nous
sommes allés avis que petit village
près de barcelone mais d'abord à
l'actualité à l'europe ou aux francs
soit hollande a annoncé de nouvelles
propositions pour sortir l'europe de sa
langueur
nous nous sommes posés la question y
at-il encore un projet
pour l'union européenne
relancé l'idée européenne et sortir
de l'europe
deux fois à longueur
vaste programme
françois hollande a lancé laurent 2 de
son enquête la part de grandes idées
réaliser une union politique lancé au
gouvernement économique européen
capable de faire converger les
politiques des vingt-sept
ou la possibilité pour l'union de lever
un emprunt en son nom propre
une communauté européenne de
l'énergie
rien de neuf sous le soleil en somme
la plupart de ces mesures sur déjà
porté par
louis colin sarkozy
ainsi une chose
alors que le parti conservateur
britannique propose un référendum sur
la sortie de l'eau
le président français a fait évoluer
rassurant
l'europe plus largement sur 10 ans la
grande-bretagne
jusque-là exister auparavant servel
un peu court d'un homme
yat-il encore un projet pour l'europe
et il ya t-il encore un projet pour
l'europe c'est effectivement ce dont
nous allons parler en avion effectuant
françois hollande ouvrir la deuxième
année de son caquet la parole des
anneaux on connaissait déjà lors de
son prédécesseur
et pour en parler tegra mois de sony qui
nous a rejoints
merci d'être avec nous
%
vous avez juste reportage avec nous
content que vous entendez le président
français qui dit de la grande-bretagne
que va-t-elle tourner a pu vivre sans
elle au début de l'union européenne
qui n'a pas de soucis
on survit aujourd'hui français
vous qui est un europhile convaincu
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
il est vrai que l'europe peut très bien
survivre sans la grande-bretagne et la
grande-bretagne pour survivre sans
l'europe mais il est possible
pour ténor français
qui est vraiment concurrentiel
la grande-bretagne apporte quelque chose
pour la grande-bretagne et l'europe
apporte beaucoup
donc nous sommes beaucoup plus forts si
nous sommes gênés
quel signe là son seul talent
merveilleuse bagarre que que font alors
bretagne et la france depuis la guerre
de trente ans
e nous aspirer et je suis sûr que le
lecteur
le président angolais chatouiller % et
son collègue monsieur carnaval qui a
ses propres difficultés au sein de son
parti concernant en ce moment mais je ne
pense pas que la grande-bretagne soit
ward sur le le le le seuil des quitté
l'union européenne
alors y'a quand même le parti
conservateur qui a déposé une loi
proposant un référendum avant 2017 7%
on est quand même proche finalement et
ont fait que
vaud pour vos beaux confrères anglais m
le porte-parole l'union européenne dans
la classe qui n'est pas à risque
pour 2010 est de voir les britanniques
sortir de l'union et de venir
comme on dit le 51e état les etats-unis
ce n'est pas un parti conservateur qui a
proposé un référendum avant 2017 chez
certains députés de son parti
donc moi avec mon jeu je suis du parti
libéral-démocrate
je regarde ce qui se passe dans le parti
conservateur avec un peu de peine quand
même content
ce n'est pas à ce que kraft très
facile mais je ne pense pas que m
mais il soit
en danger en ce moment
en partie parce que mon parti
au gouvernement faisant partie de la
collection de ne permet
et un référendum
hosono dans le coup au cours de ce
mandat
pour l'heure on voit bien que leur
client ne permettent pas mais on voit
bien que pour que monsieur cameron est
un petit peu pris au
ai-je avec cette transat bpe
europhobe si je puis dire a donc est-ce
que cette coalition tient encore la
route finalement je pense que la
coalition tiendra la route parce que la
coalition était faite pour une raison
très simple pochette faire sortir la
grande-bretagne
de ses difficultés économiques
il nous a fallu plus de temps de ce camp
croyez
mais quand même ça marche pour tenir
le coup jusqu'en 2015 cet adhérent un
parement de cinq ans
après
on va voir
mais avec le parti conservateur dans la
condition
qu'il est maintenant
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il sera réélu
par le peuple gouvernement
et donc on pourrait faire payer au moins
un joli et recevoir non réélu par
votre parti vous juge niche je ne me
fais pas trop de soucis à neige je mais
je pense qu'on pourrait très bien
envisager un mot un autre gouvernement
à la prochaine fois
il n'en est pas de même pour les siens
plus largement on voit bien que
en gala merkel est aussi prise au piège
par le système dire
ats le calendrier électoral qui n'est
pas simple et pas très élevé
françois hollande est dans une
dans quelques difficultés après
seulement une année de mandat %
cameroun et c'est pareil % au fond
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un problème de
leadership and europe aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on a pas aujourd'hui
parlons n'est pas aujourd'hui en face de
de leader qui sont
thirga un petit peu tout cette
problématique d'un point de vue
national escapa empreinte de leadership
oui je pense que nous avons en effet
quand même très grand problème de
leadership non seulement
nous avons eu trois les principaux
l'allemagne la france et la
grande-bretagne qui ont leur propre
pression
électorale et leurs propres débats
nationaux mais nous n'avons pas une
vision encore moins pour le repas
et les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
de l'ue
par mettre un visionnaire à la tête de
la commission on voit la tête du du du
conseil européen
car il faut le dire que le hamas ne
demande pas il n'est pas dans les airs g
j'ai un grand respect pour monsieur
baroin de peur et une mère un grand
visionnaire ou non je ne dirais pas
et je pense que les chefs d'état un
décret du gouvernement
on peut alors d'avoir quelqu'un
pour cela elle a accordé à
alors qu'il faut c'est les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement explique
à leurs concitoyens
quoi il laisse tomber l'europe dans ce
second temps cette condition
pourquoi ils ne sont pas capables
d'agir ensemble
car il nous faut
agir ensemble pour se sauver l'économie
de l'europe
oui mais là on voit bien que le par
exemple parmi les propositions françois
baroin avait cet espèce de gouvernement
économique de l'union
% est-ce que aujourd'hui les vingt-sept
et bientôt 28 ce que lacroix si rentre
au 1er juillet
les 27 pays vont être capables de
lâcher un petit peu de leurs
prérogatives
un gouvernement économique est une
manière de travailler ensemble sur les
questions économiques je l'espère
fourmillent
et c'est vrai que françois hollande a
proposé ce gouvernement économique
mais en effet ce que nous avons fait
depuis 2008
depuis la chute de deux lames en inde le
seul
cesser de construire un gouvernement
économique que nous avons commencé
avec un architecture heures sur la dette
publique avec
des tentatives de deux ter c'est nice
monde des banques
nous procédons maintenant avec les
procédures de la baie résolution
pour les banques en faillite nous
faisons
toute une série de chemises à carreaux
millions en 2008
nous sommes en 2013 a fait déjà cinq
ans il ya une proposition ça serait de
créer entre une forme de président
économique par exemple sera encore une
nouvelle tête
est-ce qu'il faut encore une nouvelle
tête une nouvelle institution jeff
avoir l'impression que nous avons trop
de tête mais ça reste des blessures
l'armée norvégienne nous avons le chef
de l'eurogroupe depuis qu'il prend
dans une certaine chance ce sera parole
nous avons eu aussi
grâce à dieu
un président de la banque centrale
européenne qui est parfois beaucoup
plus à gérer que nos leaders
politiques pour cent et que ce soit
monsieur trichet ou que ce soit monsieur
draghi maintenant ce sens deux clients
sunu en route l'économie européens
danser dans des temps difficiles où nos
leaders n'étaient pas capables toujours
de se mettre d'accord mais justement on
va continuer sur la question économique
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que la
france est entrée en récession deux
trimestres consécutifs de croissance
négatif puisqu'il s'agit de la paix
comme ça
mais ce qu'on ne sait pas trop c'est que
justement elle le tout la zone
économique européenne est en
récession depuis au moins six
trimestres
on a parlé sur les télévisions
étrangères cet ersatz ont préparé
par aurélie la face
02 18 cents nouveauté
la france connaît une croissance
négative l'europe s'en inquiète plus
d'un
pour le développement de l'emploi pour
les jambes cela ne change pas
grand-chose que la croissance soit
légèrement au-dessus ou en dessous de
zéro pourcent enfin dans les faits elle
est en dessous de zéro pour cent
d'une ce qui signifie que nous somme
pourrait se suffire mais en vérité ces
dernières années le phoebus de la
france a été en gros dans la même
situation de sous-emploi sens simplement
stagnante
en allemagne la journaliste dresse un
tableau noir très noir de la situation
française
hannachi acheter les mauvaises nouvelles
se succèdent la france s'enfonce dans
la récession le pouvoir d'achat suite
pour la première fois en 30 ans et le
chômage augmente et augmente 20h30
les dirigeants se retire aussi
s'inquiète
et attendent des réformes
le président de la commission rappelle
a répété avec insistance il faut des
réformes structurelles
en contrepartie du délai
supplémentaire de deux ans accordé à
la france pour ramener son déficit sous
la barre des 3% du pib et
la commission entende parler des
réformes dans le domaine des retraites
et du marché du travail notamment
graham watson depuis 2008 on annonce aux
européens ont finalement qu'on est
sorti de la crise c'est bientôt la fin
de la crise et ses terrasses qu'on leur
a menti
donc moi je n'ai jamais renoncé et si
le croire avec me ce soit parce que nous
sommes dans une impasse serbie va durer
une dizaine d'années
nous sommes à trois amis points
j'espère déjà
nous avons fait est que certaines choses
qui sont nécessaires
arkady mais je m'étais aider parce que
les gouvernements ils ne peuvent pas 2
seulement
e construire la croissance économique
ils peuvent aider la croissance
économique
mais nous avons fait certaines choses il
va nous falloir faire autre chose de
leur concert finir lala lala
larchitecture fin
pour une europe qui ces fonctionnaires
qui contre la dette de ses membres
qui control la relationniste membres des
banques
kiki
pour voir la possibilité pour les
entreprises
d'être des entrepreneurs
mais il a escaladé
on voit ça fait quand même cinq ans
maintenant kevin la grèce est en
récession
pour le portugal c'est pareil l'italie a
des difficultés l'espagne est-ce que
l'austérité est une solution pour
faire redémarrer cette économie
moi je ne parle jamais de stabilité
parce que ce que nous avions nous avons
connu ce n'est pas vraiment
l'austérité l'austérité c'est ce que
fait le tout basé sur la discipline
budgétaire
et c'est une discipline ce 5 février
ça marche déjà
qu'est-ce que c'est alors je ne suis pas
sûr que si vous dites on dirait que ça
fonctionne il met with qu'est ce qui
s'est produit dans les derniers jours
les agences de notation ont commencé à
dire que la grèce ma vie
donc ça veut dire qu'on y avait une vie
politique par rapport aux avances de
natation et non pas par rapport au pacs
faire ça moi j'étais un homme
politique par rapport au peuple et pour
le peuple c'est une bonne chose que
l'économie de la grèce soit dans une
position de croître
il a fallu faire des choses très très
difficile
elle a fallu
couper les dépenses de l'état il a
fallu
peuple
non on peut pas dire possible les
impôts passe mais il a fallu que
vous êtes à la grèce trente des âmes
pour nous il ne prenait pas en apportant
il a fallu qu'il avait retrouvé de la
ruhr éléphants l'est
tard de la grèce
pourquoi avoir la possibilité d'une
croissance économique
mais déjà avec
le jugement des agences notation ça
recommence
en portugal
tout le monde environ 42
ça recommence
amélie a lancé un inventaire acidité
pense que nous avons donné encore
deux ans
haha au portugal et à l'irlande
la réponse ne se se remettre en ordre
mais nous avons nous savons déjà que
ça marche alors dernière question
rapidement il a fallu trouver de
l'argent
et on est en train de s'attaquer aux
paradis fiscaux on a donc fait déjà
quelques années que c'était la fin des
paradis fiscaux
en angleterre vous avez les îles de
jersey edgar désert est-ce que vous
pour vous ces deux îles sont les
paradis fiscaux et à ce que la
grande-bretagne doit arrêté
duffy doit mettre au pas à ses désirs
monsieur terme bonne a écrit une lettre
quant au chef de tous les achats dite
paradis fiscaux
comme à fait et j'en suis sûr ne sur
hollande avec monaco
madame merkel avec les chiennes
schetagne ainsi pour que tout le monde
règle ce qui se passe parce que ça
change naissance tenenbaum milliards
d'un pot
la clientèle ce qu'ils sont
exactement
merci saga matin d'avoir participé à
la présentation de toute façon on
continuera de suivre ce dossier
nous on continue sur notre lancée et
direction de la catalogne habré
si une des régions d'europe avec qui
ils souhaitent accéder à
l'indépendance à l'heure où l'europe
accueillera 28ième état au 1er juillet
prochain l'acrobatie
donc direction barcelone avec
statistiques sous et sandra farkas
le sujet et parking
il envahit les conversations les
journaux
pour les catalans vont devenir
indépendant ouvert à l'obsession
nous sommes d'avis que
près de barcelone ici tous sont
persuadés que sont l'espagne
la catalogne serait plus riches il
vivrait mieux
mankazana a ainsi atteint ce stade cela
fait trop d'années que l'état espagnol
nous étouffe
la catalogne est chaque année à madrid
16 milliards d'euros et en contrepartie
on ne reçoit quasiment rien on est ado
en investissement
pour la santé ou l'éducation
on paye trois fois plus que le reste de
l'espagne
on n'en peut plus de payer autant et de
recevoir sous peu
avec la crise les gens ouvre enfin les
yeux
on se rend compte des injustices
d'autant que nous aussi
on a subi des coupes budgétaires la
récolte
aux fenêtres et aux balcons la
bannière indépendantiste frappé d'une
étoile blanche et si armand accroché
et même au fronton de la mairie
le drapeau espagnol a disparu
ici ce n'est pas l'espagne ici c'est la
catalogne on a été conquis par
l'espagne mais on n'est pas des
espagnoles pour les catalans
nous sommes une nation qui a son
identité et sa langue sa culture
nous sommes à notre pays un pays qui
n'a pas d'état
en 2009 le village s'est déclaré et
pas un catalan libre suite à un
référendum populaire
un vote pour l'indépendance qui a eu
lieu dans plus de 600 villes de
catalogne
et à chaque fois
une majorité écrasante de oui pour
s'affranchir de l'espagne
bien que symbolique cette déclaration
de souveraineté enterrer les relations
avec madrid
c'est à ce moment-là que le mouvement
indépendantiste s'est intensifiée en
catalogne madrid a très mal réagi l'on
voulait interdire ce référendum
populaire en ayant recours à la justice
l'espagne a affirmé que cet état
constitutionnel parce que nous n'étions
pas une vraie nation et ça a été
très mal vécue par les catalans
et pour ne pas relâcher la pression le
village a décidé depuis peu de ne plus
verser ses impôts locaux à l'état
central
ils sont récoltés directement par la
catalogne
une façon de répondre à madrid qui a
toujours refusé à la région catalane
l'autonomie budgétaire tant réclamée
c'est un acte de protestation et par la
même occasion nous préparons l'avenir
et notre indépendance
c'est une sorte d'exercice grandeur
nature pour apprendre à administrer
nous même nos impôts nous savons que
nous ne pouvons attendre aucune des
espagnols
car ce qu'ils aimeraient ces garder
notre argent
le processus d'indépendance se
concrétise
à barcelone on pose déjà les bases
pour la création d'un état
depuis un mois le conseil de transition
nationale travail en toute discrétion
douze membres des politiques des
universitaires ébauche les contours
d'un physique d'une sécurité sociale
d'une banque centrale catalane et d'un
pouvoir judiciaire
une feuille de route chargée
en attendant le référendum pour
l'indépendance prévue en 2014 par le
gouvernement catalan
ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait de
voir des frontières ou de se replier
sur nous-mêmes au contraire c'est la
possibilité et enfin faire entendre
notre voix à l'europe
et à l'international et de ne plus
dépendre de l'espagne pour décider de
nos politiques voilà enfin parler
d'égal à égal avec madrid la
compagnie
le rapport de force avec madrid ne fait
que se durcir
en réponse le gouvernement espagnol
continue d'affirmer
que ce référendum n'a pas aucune
valeur juridique
mais ce tacle à la carotide il est
clair que la constitution espagnole il
reconnaît pas le statut d'auto
détermination pour l'instant on va vers
une rupture avec l'état central mais
nous sommes déterminés à demander
l'accord des tribunaux internationaux
pour faire reconnaître notre
indépendance on ne peut pas bafouer
cette volonté démocratique cela ne
s'invente pas black
solution pour les hommes
catastrophe pour les autres
l'indépendance fait peur aux
industriels catalan
certains ont déjà menacé de déplacer
leur siège de barcelone
si le scénario indépendantistes se
confirme
c'est la région la plus dynamique du
pays et les exportations augmentent
pour cet économiste ce n'est pas le
moment de courir le risque de perdre de
l'activité
pire de réduire le pays d'aix
vois que je ne fus taille le risque en
devenant dépendance c'est que nous
quittions le recoupement laurent plus
l'appui de la banque centrale
européenne je vis
être en dehors de l'union européenne
revient à payer des taxes et 60% de nos
exportations de son talent destination
de l'europe
se seraient-ils pas sûr considérable
qui plomberait notre économie
sans compter que les entreprises
catalanes ne sont pas à l'abri d'un
boycott de l'espagne
plus qu'un boycott l'espagne pour elle
si la catalogne qui clignotent au pn
bloquer le processus d'adhésion
car il faut l'unanimité de tous les
pays membres
le chemin vers l'indépendance on
pourrait peut-être encore long
reportage
le pain sandra cerqueira et que cécile
ci-dessous réalisé près de barcelone
alors comment comprendre se soigner
d'indépendance y at-il un risque d'un
plan d'action anderson
nous en parlons avec notre invité
véronique de keyser bonjour à vous
cette députée européenne d'origine
belge membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères comment vous
interprétez
ce soit indépendance pour 100 euros au
sein de l'union européenne ce que vous
comprenez bien que les catalans ont tôt
orange vide de quitter
l'espagne est donc l'europe
je comprend ce qui se passait pour cent
en catalogne parce que c'est pas à eux
deux semaines 6% tous les nationalismes
et de toutes les volontés
d'autonomie ou d'indépendance ne se
ressemblent pas parce qu'il a des
contextes qu'historique propre art à
chaque pays
e il a tout de même d des facteurs qui
sont similaires dans les différents cas
je pense que plusieurs fonds ovum des
nationalistes et une histoire
millénaire en catalogne
et pour cela que tana ligne jusqu'il ya
peu
pas mal je verrai avec le gouvernement
central est de madrid départ deux
autonomie de plus en plus grands et
largement monnayer c'est une région
price
l'équipe reste
et puis la crise est arrivée
la crise est arrivée électricité
% et les situations de ce type-là
c'est-à-dire que tout à coup on va
trouver le court on le trouve en flandre
eux six mois
comme le trou
le trouver en écosse
des gens qui disent oui mais
on se sent
différents
on se sent avec une identité propre
et en plus on va payer pour les autres
et c est en général d des
réchauffistes aux niveaux annoncés
plus tard projette de l'état attaque
qui s'est constituée par exemple on
sait que nous sommes un jeune de la
solidarité
cet argent et ce n'est pas un rejet de
l'europe ne leur ferait pas au contraire
le rap apparaît comme
une ombrelle refuge oui pour r peut
continuer à vivre en tant qu'hôte
corrigés au moins dépendante que pays
arabes indépendant c'est un relais de
région par rapport à l'état central
fort pour pouvoir elle est à son
travail mais ça ça
a toujours été
rompant
mais qui aujourd'hui s'est cristallisée
6 heures les transferts de solidarité
c'est-à-dire ce sont les régions riche
qui disent aujourd'hui
je ne veux plus payer pour les plus
pauvres si nous les flamands liste
e les wallons nous coûte une demie
mercédès cela chaque année
d'orge dans chaque foyer
on paye parce qu'ils sont plus malades
que nous et puis vous le trouvez en
catalogne ont voulu trouver un écho
c'est signé il est lié les gens disent
mais qu'il serait mieux
je n'étais tout seul
le spectateur pourra mettre
ça ça fait partie du raisonnement
alors si ça devait arriver qu'est-ce
qui se passerait et ce que si la
catalogne quitter l'espagne ça veut
dire produire mankell qui traînent
l'union européenne ce que les traités
prévoir un cocktail ya deux de ses
sièges les traiter ne prévoyez pas sur
ce plan-là
et puis c'est qui essilor c'est que le
plaignant européennes
une pelle de toute façon
pop répondre
qu'à la demande d'un état c'est à
dire
automatiquement
ces six nouveaux états qui se construit
l'irak n'appartiendraient pas à l union
européenne et rené goesel dresse le
panorama est demandée
et pour s'accommoder a dit très
justement
ils ont besoin
dès la fin de la matinée
du du conseil donc ils ont besoin de
quelque part s'ils veulent faire
de s'entendre d'abord
avec hulk
l'heure ce pays
est-ce que c'est avec ce pays qui va
donner le là évidemment
si demain l'état se devait devenir
indépendante par exemple
sissi hors cote
elle devra le faire sous le patronage
bienveillante de la grande-bretagne
sussex passèrent que la grande-bretagne
était donc logique qu'elle est comme
ça entre dans l'union européenne qui
elle-même peut y rester
c'est c'est sacré
quick qui doit se passer
c'est à dire que sans avis favorable de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne c'était il ya n'aurait pas
de chance de de rentrée
ce qui serait évidemment
très dommageables du point de vue
économique pourquoi
vous craignez un risque d'implosion
d'europe où vous pensez comme vous
dites que ça n'arrivera pas justement
parce que
et traiter le prévoit pas et peut être
aussi parce que cesser
petite région pas forcément les les
les moyens d'assurer leur les moyens
financiers d'assurer leur autonomie
parce que si ça doit arriver
si un jour ça doit priver de quelque
part ça doit se faire à travers un
long processus qui est un processus de
paix
conciliation
le pays 2 d'origine j'ai bien fait
les coups de force à mon avis ne
marchandent part
et je pense que la plupart d&s des
acteurs le le savent très bien
mais évidemment
c'est pas celle du discours qui vont
faire passer une fois d'abord
provoc anita trêve je vais dire à la
population downie a pas envie de devenir
indépendante
qui après
de maître vingt ans dans un fait
accompli mais ce qu'intel
coup de force comme vous dites
le pari fait par exemple chez vous ou en
belgique
aig prise car il est arrivé de manière
virtuelle dalvik que lorsque la l2 la
radio de déchets nucléaires de type 8
ans de chez nous
annoncé par un faux journal parlé
pour ce que la belgique se diviser
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
tout le monde ya cru
tout le monde ya cru et c'était la
femme en général vous vous souvenez
sûrement de
mais cette émission financier il faut
que ce qu'imaginent à füllinsdorf bl
dans l'imaginaire des gens c'est très
possible
maintenant
si ça doit arriver en équipe
c'est annoncé j'ai des rêves
le parti elle a des pendentifs de chine
ou de la nba c dans le nord du pays et
sept à derna la partie flamande
e le score le plus élevé c'est-à-dire
un peu plus de 30% aujourd'hui
d'estimation
de vote c'est énorme
c'est le poids du parti socialiste à la
partie ouest du pays eyi le premier
paragraphe de la charte de ce parti
cette indépendance
mais maintenant c'est parti
qui a eu l'idée
remarquablement charismatique
intelligent et solidaire
d'une part des choses très différentes
par de windows
ovh bombay
ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
maintenant
le faisons des transferts de
compétences le plus important est de
plus en plus importantes percées
transfert de compétences peuvent être
le début d'un éclatement de la
belgique apparaît
et lui dire ça viendra en son temps une
parade et c'est très très intéressant
parce qu'il ya un engagement politique
contestée
il parle de l'évaporation de la
belgique
la belgique va s'évaporer peut-être
qu'en mer celtique
il est midi
et si on continue à faire des
transferts de compétences
la belgique va se creuser s'évaporait
ira plus de budget une doxa va se passer
tout seul
donc surtout pas de alors surtout pas de
panique on va être très doucement de
serre une autonomie de plus en plus
grande qui va finir par payer la
boutique
et ça c'est un processus
qui est en marche mal qu'il en soit pour
l'europe et ce que je sais c'est parti
là celui de
le rêveur ou celui de le parti catalan
est-ce qu'ils se construisent aussi se
rapprocher de l'europe pas du tout vous
avez dit que c'était plutôt contre
l'état passera rejet de l'europe pour
100 m le parti ils ont besoin de leur
appui à notre besoin de l'europe se
sont levés dd a voté un pur et dur
nous avions d'ailleurs
une représentante de la mediapad par
une collectivité publique farouche
européennes nous non
ce n'est pas en arrière la vallée
d'eure comme n'accueille pas etc etc
en grande-bretagne qui tapissent
allemande veut dire
il sortira la cour a émis des billets
beaucoup de variantes voyez-vous
il ya un acquis qui rejettera
inaki sont des parties
d'extrême droite racistes beau être
né à lesparre
populiste et qui paiera
le parti de martine aubry et d'autres l
été si l'on désire en belgique
surette des partis qui étaient
extrêmement raciste extrêmement
populiste agressif
et qui avait été durant l'hiver
2 première guerre
collaboré avec les allemands ça c'est
aussi une composante importante de ce
que les allemands
pour diviser les pays elle est
favorisée par
les mouvements un départ dentiste et
donc
e ils ont pensé que cette séquence ce
côté pro nazi
qui faisait peur à tout le monde
d où l on est arrivé il ya l'indicé
partie la cei c'est un électorat qui
s'offre qu'aux films durs
il a voulu
éviter c'est dans cette manche
mais dans sa symbolique
dans renault danse
dans la manière continue de mettre en
scène je sais ces discours
tour appel l'ordre nouveau en belgique
tous rappellent
les moments ou pelé la droite flamande
s'était rapproché de bédénik
on retrouve tout ça
mais avec des variantes de pays à pays
et c'est certainement à mon avis
attiré par la crise
le l'incompréhension des citoyens
d'une rap qui est très lointaine et qui
ne tiendraient parcours de leurs
particularismes
je crois que il ya cette idée de
particularisme dormant
on est différent
héroux la mine
nos villes différentes différents mais
en plus
ensemble dans une même union
européenne puis à faire beaucoup
véronique de keyser d'avoir inversé
sur ce plateau de rapper d'eau un
système de cette émission on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine cette fois
à bruxelles mais toujours au coeur du
parlement européen comme ces deux
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
g